[موسيقى]
عندما وصف نيكولا تسلا لاول مره المجال
المغناطيسي الدوار في عام
1882 لم يتخيل الى ما سيقود ذلك بعد 130
عاما وانه سيصبح اساسا لاختراع احد اهم
اجهزه التشخيص الطبيه جهاز الرنين
المغناطيسي فكيف حدث ذلك
استخدم مصطلح الرنين المغناطيسي لاول مره
في عام
1937 عندما طور استاذ الفيزياء في جامعه
كولومبيا ايزي دورابي طريقه لقياس حركات
النوى الذريه وسماها الرنين المغناطيسي
النووي
ماهله لنيل جائزه نوبل في الفيزياء
استخدمت طريقه ترابي في تحليل تراكيب
المواد الكيميائيه الى ان فكر طبيب يدعى
جيمون داما ديان بتجربتها على الخلايا
الحيه للفئران لتمييز الخلايا السرطانيه
حيث خلص ان خلايا السرطان ستعطي نتائج
اعلى داخل المجال المغناطيسي بسبب زياده
عدد ذرات الهيدروجين مقارنه بغيرها وهي
النظريه التي نشرت في عام
1971 في نفس الوقت تقريبا كان الكيميائي
يعمل بجد لاستخدام الرنين المغناطيسي
النووي في انشاء صور ثنائيه الابعاد
لاجزاء من الجسم ومن ثم تكديسها لانشاء
عرض ثلاثي الابعاد وهي فكره رسمها لاول
مره على منديل ورقي في الثالث من يوليو
عام
1977 انجز داماديان اول صوره بشريه
بالرنين المغناطيسي النووي وكانت عباره عن
مقطع عرضي لصدر مساعده في الدراسات
حيث كشفت الصوره عن قلب من كوف ورئتيه
وفقراته وعضلاته واص هذه الطريقه معروفه
باسمي التصوير بالرنين المغناطيسي ام ار
اي في عام
1978 اسس دامديان شركه فونار بمجال الرنين
المغناطيسي النووي وانتج اول جهاز للتصوير
بالرنين المغناطيسي متوفر تجاريا لكن
طريقته اعتبرت بطيئه جدا للاستخدام
السريري روتيني ما شجع الفيزيائي
الانجليزي بيتر مانسفيلد على ايجاد طريقه
لاكمال عمليات المسح في دقائق بدلا من
ساعات حيث تخلى عن طريقه مسح النقاط
الحساسه المعتاده واعتمد تقنيه جديده اطلق
عليها تصوير مسح الخطوط بعد محاولات عده
التقط مانسفيلد صورا لاصبع طالبه الخليج
اندرو موتسلي في 15 الى 23 دقيقه فقط لكل
قسم وهي المره الاولى التي يتم فيها جزء
من جسم الانسان بنجاح باستخدام تقنيه
الرنين المغناطيسي النووي تم اعتماد طريقه
مانسفيلد ومنحه هو واللوت البرج جائزه
نوبل في الطب لعام 2003 فيما شعر دامديان
بتهميشه واعلن عن امتعاضه في بيانات نشرت
على صفحات الجرائد فيما واصلت شركته
نجاحاتها وانتجت اول ماسح يلتقط الصور
للمريض باوضاع متعدده شهدت لاحقا الماسحات
الضوئيه سلسله من التحسينات لزياده جوده
الصوره وسرعتها وجعلها اكثر راحه للمريض
وبات هناك اكثر من 22 الف وحده للتصوير
بالرنين المغناطيسي في جميع انحاء العالم
تجري 60 مليون فحص سنويا
منذ ان توصل داما ديان واللوتر بورد الى
افكارهم الخاصه بالتصوير بالرنين
المغناطيسي فان طريقه التصوير خدمه الطباء
بمساهمات اكثر بكثير من تشخيص السرطان
وساعدت مرضى بعدد اكثر مما توقعوا